وينضم الينا من بغداد مراسل فرانس 24
ابراهيم صالح اهلا بك ابراهيم هل من
تفاصيل الاضافيه حول المواقع المستهدفه في
هذه الضربات
نعم نجيب بطبيعه الحال هذه المواقع بين
محافظتي اربيل وسليمانيه تحديدا المناطق
القريبه من شريط الحدود مع ايران على
الرغم من وقوع بعد بعض هذه المناطق طبعا
على مسافات بعيده على الاقل ثلاثه مواقع
لثلاثه احزاب تعرضت بعد منتصف الليل
الماضيه بالتوقيت المحلي في العاصمه بغداد
ل همم هذه الحكمه الايرانيه بالصواريخ
البالستيه والطائرات المسيره كما اوضحت
المصادر الامنيه المحليه في اقليم كردستان
مصادر الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني
له بعض المقرر داخل مدينه
سليمانيه قال ان احد قياده قتل خلال هذه
الهجمه مع انباء محليه عن اصابه عدد اخر
سواء من مقاتلين هذا الحزب والاسبان
الايرانيين المعارضين الاخرين داخل همم
العراق او بعض همم هو شخص واحد من قوات
البيشمركه الكرديه على الرغم من عدم تاكيد
هذا الخبر بصوره رسميه حتى الان خطوره
طبعا هذه الهجمات تاتي بسبب تطورات داخل
العنق الايراني باعتبار ان ايران تتهم هذه
الاحزاب باثاره الفوضى من خلال طبعا همم
الحث على التظاهرات والدفع بهذا الاتجاه
ودعم التظاهرات داخل المدن الايرانيه
الاسيه مع الكرديه منها اضافه الى عامل
اخر هو ما يحدث من قبل الجاره التركي من
استهداف ممثل للاحزاب الكرديه المعارضه
لها داخل شريط الحدود العراق وبعض المواقع
في شمال العراق على اعتبار ان ايران بدات
تلوح بامكانيه عشان حمله بريئه تستهدف
معارض بها داخل اراضي اقليم كردستان
العراق
بعد التلويح سيحمل نفس المبررات التي
تحملها تركيا في هذه العمليات شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه التفاصيل ابراهيم صالح
مراسل الفرنسي في بغداد